Okay,
so I was actually shitposting about this on my Instagram not long ago,
which you need to follow me on Instagram,
because the difference between my Instagram and TikTok followers is,
like, really embarrassing.
But anyway, the thing about gay son
thought daughter isn't actually
necessarily that the worst thing a person in our society can be
is attracted to men. Really.
It's the fact that gay men and promiscuous women both, um,
have abandoned the heterosexual patriarchal order of things.
Like men who only date and marry and have sex with other men,
and women who are not tied down to any one man in particular,
have abandoned the heterosexual patriarchal system of men owning women.
Gay men are not interested in oppressing women,
and promiscuous women are not interested in being oppressed
by one particular man in her interpersonal relationships.
Anyway,